my
drug of choice is uh or was and it is
marijuana
it's
that's all I
that was fine for me
um
dipping into a a little tiny baggie of
you know licking your finger and dipping
into a little tiny communal bag of MDMA
uh it wasn't gonna it was pointless for
me
when you and Miss heard got married did
you have a prenuptial agreement in place
no we did not no and why not
um
they're always
seem to be some
reason or another why she
wouldn't
either wouldn't discuss it or if we did
discuss it it became
an issue that would turn into a it would
springboard into
unpleasantness and then arguments
um
and then it was also too late at a
certain point it was just too late
so then the idea of a post-nup agreement
was brought up
to miss her and that was in Australia
that was
that was the beginning of
the Australian
well let's let's talk let's talk about
Australia then um but first of all why
were you in Australia
I was I was working on Pirates of the
Caribbean five
and who from your team was with you in
Australia
Jerry judge
Malcolm Connolly
Nathan Holmes
Stephen tutors
Keenan Wyatt
I believe that was it oh and and yeah
yeah that's it was Miss Lloyd in
Australia with you as well oh yes yes
sorry yes Miss Lord yes Miss Lloyd
traveled to Australia with us
and did Dr Kipper come down to Australia
at any point
yeah Dr Kipper down came down
a bit later
uh Mr Wyatt testified yesterday that he
observed you have a meeting with Sean
Bailey in in Australia do you remember
that
yes and could you please tell the jury
who Sean Bailey is
Sean Bailey
at that time was I believe he was the I
believe he was the number three uh the
number three man at Disney
in terms of hierarchy he was a upper
echelon Disney so he was
under Bob Iger and
initially under dick cook who was
removed from Disney
um for some reason
so yes he he's uh he was number three
man at Disney
and why were you having a discussion
with Mr Bailey
um the discussions that I would uh was
having with Mr Bailey with Sean Bailey
were
um
they had to do with well
as as I think we've established you know
I have
always from the beginning of those the
set series of films
I I had always Rewritten
um my my character's words and
and jokes if you will
um and situational comedy and things
that I would add
and uh Mr Bailey was very complimentary
about
some of the things that I'd done he'd
you know he would come over to me
laughing after that
your honor this is just disgusting
generally what they were talking about
he was getting specific I'll sustain
that if you want to continue that's fine
Mr Depp was misheard in Australia with
you
the later years do you recall when she
came down
I don't recall oh well
no I do recall it was
March
it was March
and
what happened when misheard came to
visit you in Australia
um
desert was upset because
as I stated earlier
as it was too late for a prenup
agreement there was uh
discussion of
post no agreement
and I had
called my lawyer at the time
and asked him if if he could have one of
his uh one of his lawyers
sit down with Ms heard
and and give her a basic rundown of what
a post-nuptial agreement
meant and
and they sh I was told that they showed
her children hearsay
your honor this is what something he
asked an attorney it's not a statement
of fact that's being offered for its
truth
what did Miss heard tell you she was
upset about when she arrived in
Australia
Mr told me that
the attorney that she met with
was
um
rude
and dismissive and
all she was being shown was a
an example of
a post-nuptial agreement
Mr then stated to me that she was very
upset she stated to me that
um
that she what she had said was
she said to the lawyer the woman
that this um
Johnny Cat he must not he doesn't know
about this
he's never seen he doesn't know that
this is what this is he no way he would
agree to this
um and what Mr then expressed to me was
that
the lawyer the woman
had laughed at her
and said oh he knows yes he knows
everything
um
which sent her into a tailspin
so by the time she arrived in Australia
that was sunk very deep into her
her psyche I mean so much
so that
what really what really surprised me was
that
she kept saying
I'm not even in your will
I'm not even in your will
[Music]
but that was an odd thing to say
um
especially since I I I don't think
anybody had had time to change Wills or
anything of that nature
um
so those things just didn't
it felt uh
wrong and and she could not let go of
the fact that uh
I was in on this uh postnap agreement
and that I was trying to trick her
into uh essentially getting nothing if
if something were to happen
and how did you respond to miss hurt
so I just told her those are not my
intentions
and at a certain point
you don't know what to do I mean it's
it's
the person is telling you she's telling
you you don't trust me you don't trust
me you don't trust me and um
I can't speak
about legal documents I can't speak
legalese I can't explain to her these
things all I could do was
try to calm her down and say that
I was not out to
screw her over or or put her in a
position that was uh was uncomfortable
these were stock this is normal things
to do
it did not work no it escalated and
escalated and turned into uh
Madness chaos
can you please violence can you please
describe that chaos and violence
yes she she
she was irate she she was irate and she
was
possessed uh
and when I tried to remove myself as I
normally would from a situation and that
is to say you know as she's
hammering me with with uh
sort of brutality brutal
words and
and uh you know
you know
I don't pardon
my
language but I remember
that
it wasn't nice
sort of being called in
ask history to lawyers or or uh
or a [ __ ]
that didn't fight for her or stand up
for her
[Music]
um
uh I again tried to remove myself from
the situation
um
but to no avail
as I I literally the house that
they had rented for me in Australia was
quite a large place it was quite
a bit of a labyrinth you know in a lot
of rooms
a lot of extra rooms so I would go to
well I'll I'll just cut to the chase I I
think that I ended up blocking myself in
about at least at least nine
bedrooms bathrooms
that day
um as she was banging on the doors and
screaming obscenities and wanting to uh
have a physical altercation
so how did it come to be that your
finger became injured
it was at one point where I
I'd stayed in one of the
um sitting on a bathroom floor
door locked she's banging away banging
away screaming blah blah blah and then
suddenly she stopped and I could hear
her walk away
I could hear her
should
be receding into the distance if you
will and
I I I you know
yes I so yes it became very
emotional because
you can't win for losing
there was nothing I could do to to
make her understand that I had if that
lawyer had in fact done that
and I did call
my lawyer at the Time Jake Bloom and I
had him get these people on the phone
and I
uh I'm ashamed to say that I
had taken
at that point when I was on the phone
with him I had taken
misheard's words to Heart
and um
and I laid out a ration of
of
um
very uh I was very upset that she was
pushed to that limit
because I believed it
um
and
in fact none of it had happened
so uh
it was all getting too crazy
and again I've been sober for
many many months
from alcohol
and substances aside from the marijuana
um
and I got
I left the
place the the room that I was hiding in
or not hiding locked myself into
and I went downstairs in the house there
was downstairs in the house
as soon as you walk in the house you can
go upstairs or downstairs downstairs
there was a sort of a wreck wreck area
pool table and such
and and there was a
bar
and I I was
I was a mess I was a wreck I was
shaking and I just didn't understand why
all this was happening so
I went behind the bar
I grabbed a bottle of vodka that was
there and a shot glass
and sat at the bar she was nowhere
around
and I
poured myself
two or three stiff shots of of the vodka
first taste of alcohol it had in a long
time and um
then she came down
to the bar and found me there
and of course started screaming oh
you're drinking again yeah the monster
and all that
um
so she reached
she she walked up to me and reached and
grabbed the
the bottle of vodka
and then just uh kind of stood back and
then
hurled it at me
and and it it uh
it just went
right past my head and smashed
behind me
uh
so
I stood up
and I walked behind the bar
and there was a larger bottle of vodka
the kind with the handle you know
on it
I grabbed that and I went and I sat in
my seat again
I opened the bottle and I poured myself
a shop
and drank it
lizard was
flinging insults left right and center
and
she then grabbed that bottle
and uh
and through that
at me
and the way that the
the way that the bar was situated
and where misheard was
so if if
if I could show you so if
this is the bar
where the glass was
and
the bottles
if this was the bar and I'm sitting here
like this she would grab the bottle and
she would go there she went there
and so I
was leaning like this in the chair
looking at her first bottle went
then got the other bottle shot
takes the second bottle which was the
larger one
I'm in this position again
and my my hand is on the edge of the
the bar like like that you know leaning
over the fingers
like that and uh
she threw the large bottle
and it made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and
I honestly didn't I didn't feel the pain
at first at all I felt no pain
whatsoever
when I felt was
um
I felt Heat
I felt heat and I felt
as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
um and then I
looked down and
realized that the the tip of my finger
had been
separate
and
I was looking directly at
my bones
sticking out
and uh for the
the the meaty portion of your the inside
of your finger the
um
and it was blood was just uh pouring
out
and at that point
I I
think that I went into some sort of
I don't know what a nervous breakdown
feels like
but that's probably the closest that
I've ever been I didn't
nothing made sense
and I knew in my mind and in my heart
this is this is not life
this is not life
no one should have to go through this
and and as I said this this feeling of
nervous being in in the middle of some
sort of nervous breakdown
I started to write
with my
blood in my own blood
on the on the walls
um
little reminders from our past
that essentially
represented lies that she
had told me in lies that I had
caught her in
um
and uh
and then they just
the next thing you know I
amongst all the madness I I I I would
again hide
in uh
bathroom or wherever and I texted Dr
Kipper and I said you might want to come
over uh you know I've cut my finger off
here
which finger was was cut mistered up
um it's the middle
it's the funny looking one it's the
middle finger
here you can see the
well you can see all the sort of
that they from the
initial wound this this
all these bones up here were
crushed
and it looked like a it looked like
Vesuvius in
and um
so this this
this part of my finger now is so that
because of
not having use of the tip here
this is um
basically uh arthritis
that kicks into the joint
once that once that uh
upper part of the finger is mangled
so is that the right middle finger right
middle yes yes and is that your dominant
hand
uh yes it is yes
Mr Deb after
misheard through the vodka bottle at you
and severed your finger
um
what if anything did she say when she
saw the injury
I don't recall anything but just uh
it was almost like white noise just
someone yelling it just it was just a
high pitched
constant
um
attack of insults of it was just
jumbled words to me in a very high
frequency and I I I I I was in a bit of
shock you know
I was in shock
you mentioned that you reached out to Dr
Kipper did you receive medical attention
after that
yes
um
uh Jerry judge
Malcolm Connolly
I believe Debbie Lloyd was there yes
Debbie Lloyd was there
been
King
had arrived as well who is Ben King Ben
King
was he he's he's essentially he's a
house so sort of an estate manager and
he I we worked together in London a few
times and uh
uh he's a wonderful guy so I brought
brought
Ben along to Australia to to manage
everything he's very
he's very very good and very nice
and then
there was also a
H yeah I mentioned Malcolm
and Jerry yeah they were there as well
which if any of the medical
professionals that you saw that day did
you tell what happened to your finger
I
when Malcolm and
Dr KIPP when they took me to First first
we went to Malcolm's
apartment where he was staying while we
were shooting the film
uh and tried to clean my hand because
I had worked the day before
and
obviously when you're playing uh pirate
Captain Jack or whatever they you're
you're covered your they paint with on
with alcohol
um with rubbing alcohol they paint dirt
all into your
hands and into your face and everything
so
they were they were worried about
getting my finger clean so they tried
doing that at Malcolm's and then the
chip said no we've got to get to
emergency room and we've got to get hold
of the tip of his finger so we went to
the emergency room
um the doctor asked me what happened
and I lied to him
I said that I had smashed it
in um in in these large accordion doors
that had got caught in the
accordion doors why would you lie about
that
I lied because I I did not
I didn't feel I didn't want to disclose
that it was
what it was I didn't want to disclose
that it had been
I didn't want to I didn't want to
disclose that it had been misheard that
it
had thrown the Throne of vodka bottle at
my at me and then took my finger off I
didn't want to get her in trouble I
didn't want to I
I tried to uh
just keep
things as
copacetic and as as
easy as possible for everyone I I did I
did not want to
put her name in that in that mix
did you tell Dr Kipper what had actually
happened to your finger
yes
after you returned from the hospital
where did you go
I went to
Malcolm Connolly's
um
apartment
and slept on his couch
to the extent that you know where was
misheard during this time
um
has heard
was
I wasn't there but I I had a it was
clear that she had to um she needed to
leave
and I'd ask them to get her on a flight
from
Melbourne or Sydney or wherever
back to Los Angeles
why did you ask for that
I
I
didn't want to see her I didn't I didn't
want to see her
I didn't want to have any more
arguments I was uh
for all intents and purposes I was just
done
Mr Depp I'd like to show you a picture
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 145.
what is this a picture of
that is um
that's me in the emergency room
I see uh
I see a detail that I forgot I'd
forgotten
which is the
Missouri that pulled taking my cigarette
from
the ashtray and uh
stormed it out in my
face here did you mark on the screen
where you see that
um
it's right
above that Green Dot
and do you know who took that this
picture
I do not know
uh can we please publish this to the
jury you want internet evidence yes
please any objection all right 145 and
evidence you can publish to the jury
and so Mr Deb now that the jury can see
the photograph can you again explain
um what that Green Dot is identifying
um just above the
well
just
above the green the Green Dot
is uh
uh a wound uh from
uh misheard
taking my cigarette
and and
um
this is after the finger had
gone away
um and she stubbed it out in my in in my
face and um on my cheek
so that's the result of that
could please take this um down and I'd
like to show you Mr debb plaintiff's
exhibit 144.
yep that's um
what is this a picture of Mr death
the remains of my finger
and was this taken shortly after you
were injured
I I believe this was taken at the uh
at the emergency room I'd imagine
um I'd move to this end to evidence but
I'd like to also warn the jury and the
people in the audience that this is a
very graphic picture all right any
objection
all right 144.
we can take this down thank you
Mr Depp how long after your finger was
injured did you return to LA
after the emergency room
um
the
following day I was sent to a they found
a surgeon
in uh in Australia
so that I could go they wanted me to
take X-rays taken and
and uh
all that
so we went to that doctor the finger
surgeon
um
and uh
he asked me what happened to my finger
and I again
lied
and I stuck to the story that it was
smashed in an accordion a large
accordion door
and
he looked at me as if I were
lying
and
the next thing I heard was Sir that is a
wound of velocity
and um objection hearsay
your honor this is a communication in
the context of medical treatment I'll
sustain the objection moving on
so so Mr Depp this was a surgeon you saw
in Australia yes
um when did you return to Los Angeles
after seeing that surgeon
I believe it was probably
the next day
where
might have been Kipper or someone who
who had hooked me up with a a wonderful
sort of great
expert
and reconstruction
of
you know hand the hands fingers digits
whatever
so I went to see the surgeon and um
we prepped for
surgery
you know pretty quickly
and what type of surgery did you have on
your finger
the
the majority of this was all
uh Missing
um and
essentially
to some degree hollowed out if you will
because the bone had shattered
and um then there was the bone that was
sticking out down there
so he had to
take take do a skin graft from from this
part of my hand
and grafted
um onto my finger
to to to uh to give me a finger again
anything else that was done to your
finger
to stabilize it
um
I don't think it was initially that they
put the pin in
I think the PIN
feels like the pin came
later I can't I'm not sure but
um
you just I had to go after the surgery
um it was bandaged up and
that you know they give you all kinds of
things on
what to do what not to do
keep it elevated or this or that and uh
I just uh walked away with a very large
uh
middle finger
it was all wrapped up to like this and
then
you know
uh
medicated they've given me shots in
there and such
how long did you wear that bandage that
you just described
oh the bat the bandage was from the time
of the
surgery all the way through the
remainder of
finishing parts of the Caribbean which
was uh I think I've finished
the injury took place in March
finished Pirates of the Caribbean 5 I
believe in
August beginning of August end of July
so there was a bandage on it the whole
time what I had to do was
um
where
because of um
there's a special effects
um
trick that they had planned basically
the whatever bandage I had on
as long as they could they would put
more little green dots for example on
the on the
splint and the finger and all that and
the bandages
so that in post-production they could
use what's called uh computer generated
imagery CGI
to
to erase
the bandage uh and put a
replace it with a normal finger
um that's how we finish the film
please pull up plaintiff's exhibit 61.
and if we could scroll to the second
picture or
third
can you keep going one more please
another
sorry this is a series of pictures
and to spare everyone I don't think I'll
show you the
um
the immediate injury again this is right
one right here thank you
um Mr Deputy recognize this picture
yes I do and what's reflected in this
picture
um
this was taken in the surgeon's office
um
where I'd go in okay well I had to go in
every
couple of few days to have it checked
out for
infections and such
uh and this this so the the finger
finger non-finger
was wrapped
quite heavily and there was just
medicated uh
kind of greasy medicated thing on top of
the wound itself
and this I believe seems like when the
pin was in
here and the wrapping is uh the bandage
is uh
well I had my choice you know and I
thought well
as we'll take the kitty bandages you
know dinosaurs and hearts and
unicorns
as I said you know at least at least to
have some humor uh to deflect the pain
your honor I'd like to move plaintiff's
exhibit 61 into evidence do you want the
whole exhibit or just this picture
um if we could publish uh the whole
exhibit you want the whole picture the
whole exhibit any any objection to 61.
no your honor all right 61 but you just
want to publish this part of 61. okay
thank you
[Music]
um
so how long after the your injury was
this picture taken
after the initial injury yes
I'd say no no more than
it would seem to me no more than five
days a week and how long was was this
bandage on your hand for
well I was wearing bandages all the way
up until I finished
film and then
um
yeah through through up through August
for sure and then
Beyond I I had to keep it uh
I had to keep you covered I had to keep
it protected
do you recall how long after
the injury that the excuse me how long
after the surgery the pins were removed
from your finger
so
maybe I think it was about two or three
days because I remember that there was
maybe more but I just remember that the
pain
seemed to be getting worse
and worse
as Debbie would rate it you know from a
is this an eight out of ten is this a
three out of ten
that kind of thing
um at a certain point it it
became
a kind of a 12 out of 10 because
it felt it felt hot very very very hot
and it felt uh
there was there it was there was
throbbing it was like it was throbbing
and the pin in there
I it was like I could feel the pin in
there so I I
we called the surgeon I called the
surgeon
told him actually I think it might have
been Debbie Lloyd actually called but uh
I knew I had to see the surgeon again
because something felt very wrong and I
went there and he removed all the
bandages and he found that um
that my finger was indeed infected uh
and that I had contracted a
Mirza MRSA
which is like a
I believe it's like the flesh-eating
disease or something
it was a pretty uh
it was a pretty grotesque sight
um after what the
with the pin in and what they had to do
to
save it
Mr Depp while your finger was injured
and healing did you ever take any
opiates during that time
no no no no no no
um your honor I was I'm about to switch
gears so if it makes sense to take our
lunch break all right ladies and
Gentlemen let's go ahead and take our
our lunch break come back at two o'clock
just make sure you do not discuss the
case and do not do any outside research
and we'll see you at 2.
foreign
and again sir since you're still
testifying you cannot discuss your
testimony with your attorneys or with
anybody else okay all right see
everybody at two
all right thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
all right are we ready for the jury
foreign
please
all right thank you be seated all right
your next question
thank you
Mr dupp I'd like to show you a document
that's been marked as plaintiff's
exhibit 146 and I believe this was
entered into evidence previously
so if we could publish it to the jury as
well
please
Mr Depp could you please explain to the
jury what's reflected in this photograph
well it's definitely me
um
after uh
receiving uh
kind of a a roundhouse
um
punch
um from misheard
I believe that this is a
it's a March I believe that this is
from what's been called the staircase
incident
am I correcting
so if you said you think this is from
March of 2015
um I'm just looking at the top
do you remember who took this photograph
uh Mr bet Sean Bett
and
relative to when you had injured your
finger when was this photograph taken
sorry
relative to when you had injured your
finger in Australia when was this
photograph taken
uh the
injury to my finger was sustained uh
uh
I believe it was a couple of weeks or so
before this
because I was we were back in Los
Angeles for the surgery
Rehabilitation of the uh
digit
so I know you can't see your hand in
this Photograph but what was what would
your hand have been like given that it's
injury at this date
um
well it was
it was still a very
um
It Was a Very Fresh wound
um when that amount of
um
when the
tip of your when your finger is uh
severed
um
that's not gonna heal up for a very long
time and to
so my finger was it still it was still a
very fresh wound I'm not
sure but I I'm PR I'm pretty sure that
uh
the the this might have been around the
time of the PIN
in the the pin that was uh that was uh
put into my finger to
keep it together I guess and what type
of cast would you have had on at this
time
it wasn't a cast per se as it was a it
was uh it was bandaging
um
uh when the when the when the bandage
was out to sort of hear
um that was
extra
padding for the
for the tip of the finger of protection
and and also because of the the the pin
that was in there
um
so
as I said before there were there were
when nurse Debbie would ask you know
give me you know on the scale of one to
ten your pain
uh
when the
fingers started to feel
differently and hurt a lot more and it
became like a 12 out of 10 pain
uh
that that was uh uh
yes that was right around then and the
reason for that was because of the the
infection the mersa
had already
been
working its way for
a number of days
Mr Depp could you please explain to the
jury the circumstances that led to you
having
um the bruise that's reflected in this
photograph
there
again there was another
confrontation another
another confrontation another argument
about
something or other
and
we were
we were in
we were in in Penthouse five
area which was where
Ms heard had her
office at the top of the stairs
and so the stairs came down and then
there was a landing and then another set
of stairs went down the opposite
direction
uh and this took place on the landing
um
where she was
coming out you know trying to
uh
well trying to get to me trying to hit
me
trying to do anything she could and um
and then Whitney her sister
was there who who stepped in the way
and
interesting thing that was was that
interest what was interesting was now
is that Whitney stepped in front of
Amber and was facing Amber
to stop Amber
and uh
and uh when she was in between us Amber
snuck in the Sheep reached it got the
roundhouse in and
and uh
just nailed me on the on the cheekbone
do you call recall what Mr
time
I do not I really don't
and was anyone else in the uh
in Penthouse five with you and Whitney
and Miss heard
um by that time
Mr mcgivern
have been
called I believe that actually
Debbie as I remember Debbie Lloyd was at
the front door of Penthouse five
standing by the door
Mr mcgivern was
kind of the bottom of the
last group of stairs
and uh
and then the
thump happened and
I got myself out of there out of the
situation when I walked
down the stairs to Mr mcgivern just to
say let's let's get out of here you know
and I
I remember that something was thrown
from up there I don't recall what it was
but something was uh
thrown at me it was it seemed like it
was like a
I don't know if it was a bag of
like pens or or but it was it was from
her
office area
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 343
and for the record this is an audio
recording and we it's um quite lengthy
so we intend to play certain portions of
it okay
any objection
no objection other than would just like
to know what
minute second portions
okay but the entire audio is in evidence
correct yes and no objection
343 if you'd like me to read the
specific minutes now or we can provide
it to council afterwards if you want it
now or as you
okay
uh we intend to play minute 25 37
seconds through 26 28.
um one hour and 57 minutes 21 seconds
through one hour 58 minutes 54 seconds
uh
two hours 38 minutes 52 seconds through
Excuse Me 2 hours 38 52 seconds through
2 hours 39
minutes 43 seconds
and then two hours
46 minutes one second through
two hours 47 minutes 20 seconds
those are four clips
thank you
it doesn't matter it's just audio it
doesn't matter
I
want to say something to you that it was
okay
that's that's the promise you gave me a
little while ago
I'm I'm telling you if you if you lost
memory last night of kicking me out the
door with the [ __ ] hitting me again
and you and your memory is gone from
uh you kicking the the bathroom door and
hitting me in the skull
wait sorry if you have those memory uh
uh [ __ ] you know divots upset there
was a lot going on and I was on an
ambient like why are you obsessing over
the I can't remember the way you
remembered it I said I was sorry I
didn't deny it I'm not talking about
that what I want
it it's not to get you mad it's not it's
just to get out of a bad situation while
it's happening before it gets worse in
Australia when we had the big fight
where I lost the tip of my finger
at least
five bathrooms and two bedrooms I went
to
two two two
avoid talking to me
to escape the fight you don't escape the
fight you escape the solution you escape
the solutions Escape figuring it out we
cannot work it out if you run away to
the bathroom every time listen to me
listen to me
the boxer can't go 12 rounds without a
[ __ ] minute break I'm not not giving
you minute break you do it at minute
three at the beginning of an argument
there are rounds man and when it gets
too [ __ ] hairy
the refs puts them apart or whatever but
I'm all I'm saying is
you you you can't have a solution if
the argument just keeps mounting and
mounting and mounting and mounting I
[ __ ] go to the into the bathroom and
sit on the floor Bam Bam Bam here you
come
I come out fight fight fight fight fight
crazy escalated I go split again I go to
another [ __ ] bathroom or a bedroom or
something knock knock bang bang you kept
coming to get me
foreign
that's different that's what one does
not negate the other that's irrelevant
it's a complete non-sequiturate just
because I've thrown pots and pans does
not mean that you come and knock on the
door just because there are bases does
not mean that you come and knock on the
door really I should just let you throw
I'm not saying that you're saying that
you're putting words in my mouth and
then making non-sequiturs giving you a
situation no you're trying to justify
how you don't or do come to the door
based on whether I throw a positive hand
it's irrelevant I'm justifying how you
you you
seem to think that there's this
cowardice in me that runs away and I
don't fight for you
and you're justifying that by saying I
throw pots and pans okay cool let's talk
about everything you do wrong I'm not
the one who
I said to Travis I said no I said to you
hey tell Travis we'll just happen oh
you're telling me to do it you told me
to he said go do that I said no tell
them what you're saying and I lied and
that you punched me
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
and I watched you lie and then I didn't
punch you and by the way you I'm sorry
that I didn't uh uh hit you across the
face in a proper slot but I was hitting
you it was not punching you babe you're
not punched don't tell me what it feels
like to be punched you know even a lot
of fights have been around a long time I
don't know when you [ __ ] have a
closer you didn't get punched you got
hit I'm sorry I hit you like this but I
did not punch you I did not [ __ ] deck
you I [ __ ] was hitting you I don't
know what the motion of my actual hand
was but you're fine I did not hurt you I
did not punch you I was hitting you how
are you how what am I supposed to do do
this I'm not sitting here bitching about
it am I you are that's the difference
between me and you your [ __ ] baby
because you started you are such a baby
grow the [ __ ] up Johnny physical fights
I did start a physical fight because
[ __ ] out of there yes you did so you did
the right thing the big thing the you
know what you're admirable
Mr dapp could you please explain to the
jury what they just heard on those audio
recordings
um
thank you
what what was just played on the audio
recordings
was um
very much the tone
and the
aggression and the
attitude
um and the
need
for a fight
from his hurt
that was
I don't know if that was some need for
attention but um
I don't it that that was that was a
sound
that I got you very used to
the squabbling the
the you know the the raising of the
voice to
to
essentially
excommunicate anything that I had to say
about the situation
but then
and I do remember the that incident
I believe that that's from the um
when I was
I was in the
bathroom and I I was in fact taking a
shower
and this was in Penthouse three
and she came
banging on the door banging on the door
banging on the door I didn't answer I
was in the shower I couldn't deal with
it I didn't want to deal with any more
of
of that
sarcastic demeaning
um
aggressive
violent
toxic
spew
and so I was taking a shower and I
didn't want to answer the door she kept
banging
and then I've
finally got out of the shower and I
opened it
bathroom door about
I'm just that that much just so I could
have a a good hold on the door
in case you tried to
burst in
and
I was right she did
she tried she was
bathroom doors go in she was pushing her
all her weight on the door trying to get
in
and I was pushing back because
I I didn't want to let her in because I
didn't obviously didn't want the
conversation she was not in
the best of moods you can you can hear
uh
so when I
was pushing the bathroom door trying to
close it
and was almost closed
she suddenly kind of yelped in in pain
and she she screamed out ow my toes are
my foot or something
and so in that second I thought
possibly her her foot had gotten caught
under the door
which would of course not feel great on
the foot or the toes so I thought she
was maybe injured so I
I knelt down
to have a look the door was still it was
it was still pretty well
about
that much open and when I knelt down uh
all my hands and knees to look at her
foot to see the injury
um
she kicked
uh the bathroom door
uh
into my
head it so it
it um
yeah she kicked the bathroom door into
my head
and uh
I was I was completely
taken aback by
such a a
corrosive
horrific move so I stood up and I
believe I said
I stood up and I
but but this at this point the door was
open I stood up and I said I think I
said
I think I said what the [ __ ] was that
what the [ __ ] was that
and um
the next move was just a bang it'll just
uh she clocked me in the jaw
and uh
I was another shocker
so after that did you start recording
sorry how long after that did you start
recording that audio recording that we
just heard the the audio recording was
about
her
trying to make less of what had happened
in fact
trying to make less of what had happened
by
repeating some story to me that didn't
make any sense and
it certainly didn't make any sense since
I was there and I was the target
so I wanted
some confirmation from someone with some
semblance of
a a mind that could
understand what was happening oh I
wanted Mr mcgivern to come up and I
asked her to tell him
what had just happened
and
her answer was essentially I don't know
what he's talking about nothing happened
he's fine
and um
once again
I told Mr mcgivern
time to leave the premises
Mr dupp I'd like to show you now what's
been marked as plaintiff's exhibit 162.
you can take this down thank you
could you pull up plaintiff's exhibit 92
please
Mr Depp what is this a picture of
uh that's that is a
that's a photograph of
uh the blade of uh
of an old like like a buoy knife
um
that's the photograph of the blade
with an inscription on it to me from
Ms heard who at the time I referred to
as Slim
um your honor we'd like to move exhibit
um 90 26 event 92 into evidence
um no objection
Mr dub what does it say on this knife
and what does that mean
until death
and then what does it say after that XX
Slim
and who is Slim
insert
when did Miss heard give you this knife
well it was a present for miss her I
believe it was around 2000
and 15.
could we please take this down and pull
up plaintiff's exhibit 93
93 93 yes
Mr dupp what is this a photograph of
that's the um knife in full view that's
the full
side of that knife
uh we plaintiffs would move plaintiffs
exhibit 93 into evidence as well
three in evidence you can publish the
jury
Mr Depp do you recall the occasion on
which misheard gave you this knife
we call exactly the occasion whether it
was uh
my birthday
of 2000
um
15 or if it was a Christmas gift
um
we can take this down please thank you
Mr Depp I'd now like to show you what's
been marked as plaintiff's exhibit 65.
and I believe this has already been
offered into evidence if so if we could
please publish to the jury thank you
Mr Depp what's reflected in these
photographs
[Music]
there were some scratches
um
a
another
altercation and there were some
miserted
come at me with her nails her hands
scratch scratching
at me
and who took these photographs of you
once again I believe this was Mr bet
Sean pet
and when were these photographs taken
seems to be Christmas
or 10 10 days before Christmas the 15th
of
December 2015
Mr duck do you remember what led to you
having these scratches on your face
This was um
yet again another confrontation
where
um
as was my
regular practice there had been an
altercation she she was
um
yeah
some
rage issue with me and
I remember that I was
trying to go to my corner as it were
which is I went I was going into my
office
in the in Penthouse 3 which is upstairs
and as I was approaching the door to my
office
um Miss heard
ran out of the master bedroom or a
bedroom and uh
started
just throwing wild punches at uh
uh at me at the back of my head at the
side of my head that my anything that
she could connect with and um
I had to
I
I would have to show you
uh
sort of the
how
I tried to avoid the uh
attack if it's all right yes sir if if
I'm walking
this way to the door of my office in the
bedroom the door is where you are
I've walked across the the
mezzanina and as I'm approaching the
door
suddenly
I'm just getting clobbered from behind
and
and one's natural
Primal instinct is to
kind of Duck and Cover so I dubbed and
covered
but they didn't stop
so I
I came up this this like this
um sort of protecting my face but at the
same time
with their arms swinging wildly
I
put my arms up and I
I was able to get her into a
like a bear Huggers just to
to
stop her from
hitting anymore
um
and well
holding her in that position
she was still
trying to
you know she had her legs she had her
she could kick she could you know she
could knee me
oh so she was still
um jumped you know kind of
very angry very animated
and uh
yeah
that was unpleasant
what happened at the end of that
situation
because of the
grabbing of the arms and and holding
them to her sides
so that I didn't receive any more blows
um and and she was still fighting
I believe there was some kind of contact
with our
heads or foreheads
as would happen if you're trying to
calm someone like that
um
and then
that was when she
accused me of head-butting her of giving
her a head Putt and uh
breaking her nose
but um
there was
there was no blood
there was no I I didn't hit her nose uh
if there was anything at all it was a
it was a bump of
well
I'm trying to restrain her she's trying
to get out of it
there's going to be some contact here
and there accidental contact but
not a headbutt
how did you escape this altercation
after she'd made the remark about
the fact that I
had butted her
which which was just
impossible
um
she
she split she
she
huffed off at my let her go she Huffs
away and she was gone for about
seven or eight minutes
and then when she came back I was in
the I was then I was in the bedroom of
Penthouse three
our bedroom
and she came back about seven or eight
minutes later
and she had a Kleenex
or of tissue to her nose
and um
and she then she pulled it away from her
nose and she showed it to me
and there was red there was indeed like
red color on the
on the tissue
but me I know that there was no
connection
to her nose no part of my body made
connection to her nose or
eyes or anything like
so she said she took it away and she
showed it to me she said
way to go Johnny you broke my nose
you broke my nose
and I knew I hadn't so I said
in you go into sort of
placation mode which is oh my God let me
see are you okay what happened let me
see
and she wouldn't let me see anything and
so
I just tried to calm the situation as
best I could
um all the while
I was waiting for her
to dispense with that Kleenex because I
didn't trust it
and so I waited
and went
she
dropped it into the waste basket in her
bathroom
or in our bathroom
and left the room
went somewhere downstairs I think I
don't know and then I pulled the kleenex
out of the
out of the trash bin
and I inspected it pretty closely
and realized that it was nail polish
there's no varnish or polish
Mr Depp shortly after December 15 2015
where did you and Miss heard go for the
holidays
it was uh had been planned for a while
that we would be going
to the island
and we would be going to the island with
my
um
who my kids
um Lily Rose and Jack and Lily Rose's
boyfriend at the time
uh and and um
uh there were there was a friend
of Amber's called uh Alice temporary I
believe her name was is and her
boyfriend Greg Williams who's a a a very
well-known photographer and uh
both very nice people and their kids
were going to she told me they were
going to become to the island and I've
flown okay great
um [Music]
and so yeah that's
that's so that's where we went for the
holidays
and what happened on the island in
December 2015.
many things
um was there any violence
by misheard against you
oh yes there was uh there were a couple
of incidents
that were
again just
each time
the one of these incidents would occur
if
it seemed to get worse
and worse
that is to say
as opposed to fists or anything like
that
um
I had set up on the on the back porch of
the house I'd set up an area
um with a an easel and oil paints and
a can of mineral spirits linseed oil
brushes everything so she wanted to
paint
so I had set it up for
uh and and for some and again
I remember sitting at the table where
most of the
uh
paint brushes in the can and all that
stuff was
and uh
the argument
again escalated escalated escalated and
she
just simply reached down and grabbed
count of the kind of mineral spirits and
uh
and uh chucked it at my face she threw
it at my face and it
it uh
it it it it
struck me right at the bridge of the
nose
so the forehead Bridge of the nose area
and
it hurt
who else was around when this happened
well thankfully my children and Lily
Rose's boyfriend were over towards the
cafe
at that point I didn't know that anyone
else had
was around or had witnessed anything
I thought it was just Amber and I but
apparently
um
there are four staff who who work on the
island
statements yet
your answer sir okay
um
um
sorry this the staff that work on your
Island Mr death yeah
so there are indeed
for staff who work on on the island and
live there
all year round
who take care of everything and
uh
two of them
happen to be in that area and witnessed
the
violence how sustained as to
unless you can lay a foundation how he
would know certainly if it was not
hearsay Mr Depp how do you know that
these staff members witnessed part of
this altercation
these people as I said there's there's
stuff on the island though I consider
them family
and very dear to me
and I I believe it is mutual I've known
them a very long time
um
they were visibly
um they were visibly shaken by what
they'd witnessed again if you can lay
Foundation if he saw them there or if
this is something Mr adapt did you see
any of these individuals shortly after
you had this altercation with misheard
no that's not the that's not the proper
were they did he see them as actually
there if he didn't if it was something
they told him then it's hearsay Mr Depp
did you see any of your staff members at
the house when you and Miss hurt had
that altercation
once Miss World had stormed off
um
I sort of sat there Dazed and Confused
for
uh
a few minutes and then I walked
around the house
and I
saw Tara and
that's fine
I'll sustain the objection we move on
you mentioned Tara who's Tara Tara is
the manager of the island
Mr dupp I'd like to discuss April 2016
now
um
when is when is Miss heard's birthday
22nd of April
and in 2016 how was misheard celebrating
her birthday
um
we'd set up a
dinner
for her which was she wanted to
have a dinner
um with her
with all her friends and uh
Josh Drew
um
Rocky's Rocky's boyfriend who was some
sort of Chef
uh told
he asked her what she would like
for him to cook
that's hearsay I guess yes
I know I just Sheriff's offered for the
truth of the matter asserted he got it
okay all right well then
uh let me put it a different way
Mr Drew who was a chef
which I don't believe is hearsay
Mr Drew had made Mexican food
Ms hurts favorite
is that better
and and what were you doing that day
before Miss heard's birthday celebration
um I had been in a room
for many many hours
with uh
a group of a group of accountants
um new accountants
and
they were going through
essentially the situation that I was in
financially which was uh
um
a real shock to me I
I had no idea
and I know this sounds ridiculous but I
prefer to think of the work as opposed
to how much I'm getting paid so I
I had no idea how much money I'd made I
I just didn't I just figured if I was
working
there was money
so everything would be all right
um
they informed me that I had been
um
well quite quite a
an inordinate amount of
sum of money had been
was gone
it had
disappeared
and
after having worked 30 something years
in the industry
I'm sorry I could hear Miss Brett you're
fine go ahead sorry
good uh
I was pretty shocked at where
um
I was
to learn I I I was
exactly financially and uh it was a very
long meeting
and I knew of course that Ms herd's
birthday dinner was destroyed at I
believe 8 30.
and uh
I texted her a number of times uh
from the meeting saying
this is this is uh probably going to go
long
and I think I might be a little late I'm
sorry
but it's you know important and I'm I'm
I I'm gonna be
a bit late for the dinner
and I apologized all over the place and
so
when I left
um and picked up something at the house
which I believe was your gift
um
on the way down town
I received a text from Miss heard asking
me to
bring
asked if I could bring
some wine
and some weed
and I texted back
sure
and then by the time I got to arrived
Penthouse five
for the party I was about an hour and 40
minutes late maybe something like that
before you arrived how many drinks had
you had
oh I think I'd had a glass of wine with
it was there was one bottle of wine
that Ed White had brought to the meeting
that we'd
between I don't know how many five or
six of us we had a we
had a glass of wine could you tell the
jury who Ed White is oh yeah sorry Ed
White was my at the time he was my um
the new business manager
um and he was quite a
um
he was quite a professional you know
nearly forensic
business manager and he had
shown me things that that from from from
my former business managers were quite
disturbing
hearsay
I believe he said he showed him
yes he should yes I looked at papers
maybe they're hearsay papers
I believe he was being shown financial
documents all right all right so well
also saying listening here say that mine
understood next question
um Mr Depp when you arrived at the party
how did Miss heard greet you with at all
very cold
what did she say to you
not much
not much except
occasionally she would tear herself from
the conversation that she was in and
just to
lean towards me I was I was sitting to
to her right
and I would get a quick ear full of
I can't believe you I can't believe
you've done this to me on my birthday I
can't believe I'm so embarrassed
um you know
which I found odd because
I kept her informed all all day and the
last text that I'd received was a
request for wine and marijuana
so when I got there and received that uh
attitude
uh what can I do
um
so I just made the best best of it
and talked to her friends and uh
because they were all her friends except
for I believe nurse Aaron Aaron was
there I believe what's Aaron's last name
uh Aaron Borum nurse Aaron who had been
the nurse who signed to measured
so I just I I just had conversations
with the various people there her makeup
artists
um
Melanie Iglesias was there with her
fella and
I remember speaking French with them
and
I didn't really eat wasn't
feeling it
did you have any drinks at the once you
arrived at the birthday party uh
wine
how many glasses
maybe two maybe because they were like
Lord you know the large sort of
um Bordeaux glasses
so yeah maybe two two glasses of wine by
the time it started to wind down
how many
um how many drinks Did You observe Miss
heard consume after you arrived at the
party
I I really couldn't say because I I
I
all I saw was just there was
she had a
she was drinking wine
and did it seem to you that she had been
drinking wine prior to your arrival
um
I was sure since I was an hour and 40
minutes late that
Ms heard was
well into the wine before I got there
yes certainly
how did the party come to an end
it was kind of
you know one person would say well I
better get out of here and then two more
couples or two more people would say
yeah time to go
and then it just uh wound down there was
Mr Drew
Miss Pennington
um
Whitney possibly Whitney
and that was about it it was sort of
left there
and what happened after the guests left
the party
um
she was free to
to commence with the uh
the usual verbal
barrage
and I
at that point
there was so much in my head from the
meeting
I thought it was a bit much
that misheard had
I'm sorry it seemed quite
bratish it seemed quite childish
that misheard was holding a
such a grudge against me for having been
late to her 30th birthday party
when she knew very well she was well
informed that I was in a an intense
meeting
that had a lot to do with not just my
life and my future but my children's
and what would
I didn't know what was going to happen
to
[Music]
I didn't know what was going to happen I
didn't know if houses were going to
start going away I didn't
so um
it felt
it it
I'm sure of course you felt something
but it felt
unfair it felt small
comparatively if you're
a loved one or your husband
uh has had
some very serious issues brought before
him
um so uh when she engaged in her normal
kind of banter of
uh trying to poke at me and get me to
react
I literally just got into
I got into bed
um I remember the television was on
and I and I was reading
and I said it's a suppose mustard was
down in her area
taking off her
makeup and changing into sleep clothes
whatever and uh
she entered the bedroom while I was
laying on my side of the bed
reading
and
she was still
rattling off all the
wrong side I'd done to her in that
particular day and and how unreliable I
am and
uh what a you know what a
horrible person I was
um and I and I didn't not I did not
engage
verbally nothing I sat there or laid
there
reading my book
and when that and she didn't get a jump
out of me or a jolt out of me
she got out of bed
she walked around the bed she came to my
side
and again
you know you you've got uh
you've got a person who is uh
throwing multiple
shots at your
at your face at your head at your neck
at your at anything she could hit
so
I I got up out of bed
and I grabbed her by the shoulders
sat her down on the bed
and I said I'm leaving
please don't get off the bed please
don't follow me please don't try and
stop me
I'm leaving
and she got up
off the bed
and she squared off at me in the doorway
of our
bedroom
and I said what do you what do you want
to do hit me again would you like to hit
me again
and I said go ahead
hit me
and then I just said did that is that
what you wanted
would you like another
bam
there's the second one
and I said good now you're done
grabbed her by the shoulders
walked her to the bed sat her down and
said
don't follow me leave me alone
I'm out I'm gone
I went I grabbed a few things
and I got out immediately and I went to
um
my other house on sweet sir
as misheard with she was leaving
the following day for
Coachella which is a a it's a
coachella's like a it's a big event a
concert you know many many bands and
um yeah out in the desert she she and
her friends were going to Coachella for
the weekend
and um
that was it that was that was it
Mr Duff after April 21st 2016 when was
the next time that you actually saw Miss
heard in person
I left Miss heard well
I left Penthouse three I left
at 4 30 in the morning
uh
on it was actually April it was actually
her birthday it was four four Thirty in
the morning April 22nd
and that's when I left and from that
moment on
I did not see
misheard until
May 21st and why was that
um
I had received some news
that was
as absurd
and grotesque
and
cruel
um
and then I was shown a picture
of what the problem was I had gone to Mr
bet
and said
she's in coach she's at Coachella I
think it's a good time to go downtown
so that I can get some of my things you
know
and get them out of there especially the
things that were
precious to me you know
children things things from
friends Brando Hunter Thompson whatever
things that were important to me and he
said I don't think now is a good time to
go
and I feel like it's the perfect time
she's not going to be home for two days
and then he showed me a photograph
on his telephone
of
objection
it's a photograph your honor
as being relayed to him by Mr bet he
says he looked at it on his on his phone
all over the objection is the photograph
what was the photograph of Mr Depp
it was a it was a
it was a photograph of the bed our bed
um and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter
so I understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
um
my initial response to that was
I mean I laughed
it was so
outside
it was so bizarre
and so grotesque
that I could only laugh
um
and um
so I did not go down there that day
Mr debb how was your mother's health
during this time
[Music]
not good not good at all my mom
my mom was in um
Cedar Sinai Hospital
and
she was
she was on her way out
she was dying
how often were you going to see her
during this time excuse me how often
were you going to see her during this
time
um
as much as I could under the
circumstances
um
but and
when I when I
when I did go go and get to see my mom
um
she was pretty much
incapable of speech
Her speech had left her at that time her
she was she was she seemed her eyes were
still open and she was
we could
kind of react with her eyes but she
couldn't speak
and then not long after that
once her eyes closed
she lay there
for the duration
of her
of her life which ended on
the 20th of May
um and then the night before I
Psalm is heard
for the last time well
essentially
I'm so sorry Mr Depp but how does your
mother's death affect you
as would anyone I suppose
there was one thing that I couldn't
fathom was
I mean I
I brought my kids to see Betty Sue in
the hospital and
at that time she was
not functioning she was not responsive
she was alive still she was fighting
still inside but she was
she was uh
lying in the bed
um
and what excuse this analogy but
all I could think of was
how
if if she's conscious
of of if she's conscious
of everything that's going on around her
but has no ability to
speak has no ability to
move
um
I I knew that
the one thing as far as Betty Sue was
concerned
the last thing that she would have
wanted was
to have ended up lying there
on a what what it was like
there's my mom lying there on a deli
platter
and it was a it was a horrible image
but I brought my kids in to say goodbye
and we all spoke into her ear
and uh
and then
she passed away later
so it was uh
it was painful but there was some side
of it too
at least to me
that in in in a way it was uh
I was happy for
I can't because I can't imagine Betty
Sue or my mom I can't imagine anyone
lying there
in quite
probably
quite possibly was a uh a kind of a
locked in syndrome
and if she's surrounded by
10 people looking at her lying there in
that on that Deli platter if you will
I
was happy for her that she was out of
pain out of frustration out of
I I was happy that she'd moved not happy
I was relieved
that she was no longer in that situation
though
when
those you love
leave
we're the ones
stuck with the uh
with pain with The Grieving
um
but I was glad that my kids got to see
her and
give her her her her her
send off I suppose and
um
but it was no no it it
opened my eyes quite a lot to a number
of things
and what were some of those things that
your mother's death opened your eyes to
that life is a bird song
that
that what feels like
a hundred years is in fact
a second
millisecond
nobody can count those things you know
so
I have made
peace with Betty Sue because I
understood where she came from and I
understood how difficult her childhood
was and I understood that she had
had not had the
proper training or proper
teaching or the proper
background
to to be anything other than what she
had been when we were younger
I I forgave her for all that
um
as one
would should
so I was
it opened my eyes to the fact that that
that
yes
try in relationships
whether
friendships whether courtships whether
marriage whether this with the try your
best try
if it's not going to work it's not going
to work
and
and and more importantly
if you're going to get out of it if
you're going to make an end which I
had decided that I I it was somebody had
to call it and I decided that I would
call Amber
and tell her that my
mom had had died that day
and then I
very
calmly
said look
I've I've made a decision and I think
it's the best thing
I'm going
I'm going to file for divorce
but I'm not going to I'm not I'm not
gonna
cite irreconcilable differences I'm not
gonna cite any violence I'm not gonna
I'm going to State this
we simply
the two of us
we simply
don't
want to feel
as though we we have a a collar
around each other's neck and a leash
attached to it and then this piece of
paper that proves that that's true so
what I thought was best was
we want to end this in love and take the
idea of
ownership
ownership of one another out of the
picture and and that's how I approached
Miss hurt
um with that
and uh
so so why did you go over to the
penthouses on May 21st 2016.
misheard requested uh
that I come over to
to have a talk to explain she wanted to
explain things and
and uh so I went there but and I also
had to
wanted to gather up some of those
things you know
precious things that you
live with
um
yeah so I went over there
to have a discussion what I thought
would be uh
calm
understanding
and I thought I figured she understood
as well as I did that there was no way
back and I I also felt that she would
understand
that
um
it was the best thing for both of us and
there were no
uh
there was nothing to there should have
been nothing to fight over it was clear
I told her that I would take care of her
and
all that and um
and then she
she started to she was telling me about
the uh
she brought up the situation of the
her
fecal matter on the bed
and
I
and she just tried to blame it on the
dogs
why didn't you think it could have been
the dogs
The Dog's Way
the
their teacup yorkies they weigh about
four pounds each
um
the photograph that I saw
and and I I mean
I lived with those dogs for many years
and so did
Hilda Vargas
um
my
she's a she's a woman who's been with me
for 30
plus years you know from the very
beginning
and she was the one who photographed it
um
it was clear
she knew the dogs as well as I did
that was not none of that did not come
from a dog
I just didn't
Mr could we back up a little bit who
went over to the penthouses with you on
May 21st
I went to the penthouses
with
Jerry judge and Sean Bell
and I had asked them
on the just in case
he
please
pay particular attention
and stay as close to the door you know
stay at the door or if you've got a
split come back quick you know if they
went down to the
security shock or whatever it was
come don't don't linger get back because
if you hear anything if you hear
uh screaming
you've got to get in there so leave the
door unlocked
and and spring in there if you hear
something
why did you want them to be able to get
into the penthouse quickly if they heard
anything
um
based on my past experiences with
Missouri when
when you say something that that she is
either didn't agree with or swore up and
down that it was a complete falsity and
there was something wrong with me I'm
crazy and you know the escalation
if if anything was going to start to
escalate
I did not want to be there
so I had them
waiting by the door
to get in there in case anything went
down
so when you walked into the penthouse
what did you see
when I first walked into the penthouses
you you walk in and then make a left
and then you're in the kitchen area
and then beyond that was
the living room
um
uh I saw Miss heard
sitting there
on the couch
um
and I went over to
talk
well I went and sat down on the couch
she was sitting on the couch was kind of
a
you know a square or a half Square you
know
she was sitting on one side of the couch
I was sitting on the other [ __ ] that's
when she was trying to explain
a few things about Coachella and
then the fecal uh
delivery
um
and say saying that it was the dogs
and I I could I'm sorry I could not
agree with her I'd lived with those dogs
I picked up their fun it was not
the dogs
and so what happened was
I called I said let's call Kevin
Murphy who's Kevin Murphy Kevin Murphy
had been he was he was in Los Angeles he
was he was the
um
the house manager over
the places in West Hollywood and he was
also
um taking care of the the penthouses
downtown
if any work needed to be done or this or
that and he would schedule the the girls
who would come in the the ladies like
Hilda to
do their work and
um he'd had a conversation with Ms heard
here's how your honor
let's move beyond the conversation that
Karen Murphy had with Miss heard
um so after you called Kevin Murphy what
happened
I asked
Kevin
if Amber
and he had spoken
about the incident
he said yes they had
okay
and um
it appears that Miss heard had told him
apparently a statement by misheard that
he was that he heard from Kevin Murphy
that's what the testimony is all right
if you want to reframe that that's fine
okay
after you hung when did you hang up the
phone with Kevin Murphy
um right about the time that Ms heard
was screaming obscenities Adam and
calling him a liar and that he was a
scumbag and
I I told her I said listen to
don't speak to this man that way do not
desperate disrespect this man in that
way and then Kevin Murphy just hung up
and so at that point
she was riled of course
and I went upstairs to gather belongings
when I came back downstairs she was on
the phone with
IO till it
right and they were
making a
a wonderful point of just how funny it
was
that um
I thought that some human being had
actually
dropped a
grumpy
pardon term
onto the bed
and they were yeah they were yucking it
up they were laughing about the whole
thing and
uh
it was it was
you know it was a it was it was a tough
couple of days
and I really didn't
feel like I deserve that
kind of treatment
and
I went over and I said let me talk to
her I grab the phone and I said to IO
you can have her now she's yours she's
all yours
right
and then I took the phone
and I
just bang like that onto the
I mean that side of the couch was eight
feet long the other side of the couch
was about six feet long
I flopped it onto the couch and I was
walking towards the uh
kitchen
to uh
exit and then
suddenly Rocky
Pennington
um
ran in
to the penthouse
and started you know leave her alone
Johnny leave her alone
I was I was by the
refrigerator at this point I was 20 feet
away where it was misheard at that time
she was still sitting on the couch
um
and that's when the screaming you know
the
um the screaming
started
with like
again I'm 20 feet away
she's still got io on the phone
she's got rocky there
stop hitting me Johnny she's screaming
in in her best
um
freaked out
upset voice high pitched
stop hitting me stop hitting me Jerry
judge
and Sean that entered the room
and as they entered the room and she was
quite surprised to see them she said
that's the last time you'll ever hit me
that's the last time you'll ever do that
to me
and again I'm a good 20 feet away by the
fridge
and then Jerry said boss I think we
should just leave and then we left
that was the last
time I saw misheard
until
um
until she asked me to break the
restraining order
or not break the restraining yeah break
the restraining order and talk to her in
July
later
Mr Duff where did you go after you left
the penthouses on May 21st
I went home
to to which home oh to Sweet sir
and then where did you go did where did
you go after you went home to Sweet sir
um I was due to um
I I I had to go
to I had to catch a flight to New York
where we were doing that I was this
group The Hollywood vampires
we were about to set out on a
two or three month tour of Europe and we
we were rehearsing in New York
and then we played one show
in New York as a as a warm-up gig and
then we were on the plane and we were
we started the shows in in
Europe and I was on the road
from then which was May
on through July uh August or something
I was just going to suggest that thank
you you're all right thank you let's go
ahead and take our afternoon break
ladies and Gentlemen please do not do
any outside research and do not discuss
the case thank you
foreign
take our recess Mr Depp you know what
I'm going to say right you're learning
right okay uh 3 45.
thank you all right
the jury comes in just for your exhibits
92 and 93. if I could get a hard copy of
those they're not on the thumb drive for
some reason and in my binders it says
produced in Native format and I don't
know what that means
okay so if we could just get those two
and hard copy I'd appreciate it
absolutely are you ready for the jury
yes
foreign
thank you all right your next question
ma'am thank you
um Mr Depp I'd like to show you another
audio recording that is plaintiff's
exhibit 397.
um and for the record we intend to play
the portion that is one hour four
seconds to one hour two minutes and 50
seconds all right so there's no
objection to 397 coming into evidence in
its entirety
okay audience coming in it's 397 in
evidence and then you want to play that
part that's fine
it's
fine
let me show you
well those wishes don't come true
you know what I mean yeah I wish you the
best hey buddy you [ __ ] yourself
suck your own dick
oh
I'll write your check for the extra sip
I took is that okay
you're the one that brought her though
you did you said don't drink my wine
that's mine
I didn't say that oh you didn't I said I
didn't think you were looking for
anymore rewind
probably definitely be pretty good in
front of you
Rocky and your pop and uh
your mom
so good at it
you
I've tried so [ __ ] hard with you I've
tried so hard
[Music]
to God
oh good God Jack's stepfather teaches
him more about the new man they need a
[ __ ] in here
hey that's good you gave me some [ __ ]
about my kids just like in London that
you desired
foreign
stay away
you don't exist
you will not be getting
my words
Mr debb could you please describe to the
jury what they just heard in that audio
recording
foreign
clearly there was some
uh
animosity
and uh
another
Clash
and um
miss her
once again
felt it necessary to
bring my bring my kids my my son into
the
into that argument and say that
she hopes that
my
Sons
stepfather
can teach him
how to be a man
since I couldn't
um
and I believe she says something about
more man and The Stepfather than
would be existing in my
believe the term was left nut
how often did Miss heard bring your
children into your arguments
too often
and at the end of your relationship how
was Miss heard's relationship with your
children
non-existent
they
my
children
my kids are far
um
more intelligent
than I am
and they they broke
[Music]
they they
wouldn't be around Ms heard anything
they refused to be around her
anymore
they didn't like
the way she treated me
which was written in a
a a a very elegant letter by my daughter
actually to to miss hurt
I don't know if that's in evidence but
I remember the uh
my daughter
sent a text to Miss heard
objection your honor just hearsay it's
one thing for the witness to tell his
story it's another thing for him to tell
other people's stories you can move on
okay I'm sorry I read the
I read the email yeah I understand next
question
um when did you learn that Miss hurt had
filed for divorce
um
well it was
let's see Betty Sue was the
20th
that night I spoke to her about the
divorce 21st was the
um kicker
I believe
it was on the 20th 23rd
and I had already left
town for New York to prepare for the
tour
did Miss heard know that you were out of
town at that time
I don't know
when did you learn that Miss heard had
made domestic abuse allegations against
you
um
the 27th
of May
which in fact my daughter's birthday
um
I
saw that she had gone to a
Court it was I don't know some court and
there were Paparazzi everywhere and her
and
a brown mark on her face
um
and it was also happened to be the day
that
Charlie and the
no Alice in Wonderland 2
um so the Looking Glass was opening and
that's the day that she chose to uh get
the
go go to the courthouse and get a tro uh
temporary restraining order against me
but I was
in Europe already at that point
Mr Depp I'd like to show you what's been
marked as plaintiff's exhibit 487.
and just for the record this is a very
long document and we will be showing
pages
470 or excuse me 492
through
494.
there's no objection to
the document 487.
um
okay
I assume are you entering this in
evidence now are you just showing it I
can I can give them an opportunity and
go through it with Mr Depp if that's
okay
um
Mr Depp do you recognize any of these
text messages that are on the screen in
front of you
um
vague
memory of of these and who were these
communications between
uh looks like myself in the it's me
um in the in the green
and Ms heard's words in the blue
and do your Communications reflect that
misheard understands that you're in New
York
I'm sorry
what is the date of your text messages
here on this page
um
that's the 23rd of May 2016.
hers are the 24th
of May two thousand
sixteen
and based off of these communications
does this refresh your recollection that
Miss heard knew that you were in New
York on this date
um
in her text you know
when do you leave
um
what was clear that I was
leaving
um
right away but uh
I I'm not sure that I wasn't already
because
I wasn't in New York City we weren't
playing New York City we were we were
playing
we were rehearsing in a um
like a casino
because you know and that was where we
did our first uh
show
um
to Pratt you know first show The
Practice for the
the tour the European tour
so I don't know if I was
either
leaving for New York but I don't I think
I was already there because
New York City
uh
we weren't uh I don't know recall that
we were
playing New York City
she might be able to see suggesting
going going there
I don't know
could we please turn to pay
40 excuse me 494.
and Mr dub do you see the text message
from Miss heard on May 24 2016 at 6 33.
yes I do yes I do okay
and
do you understand what misheard is
referring to in this text message
um is it all right if I just take a
quick glance please do thank you
thank you that's better
wow
I remember yes
my recalls
and what do you recall about this
that it made no sense to me
it it
just didn't
make any sense to me
especially about
well as long as you don't file
nobody will know
it just didn't I again I'm not all that
familiar with these types of things but
if
I mean if it's two people in a
relationship and the relationship is
ending
um
in any case the outcome is
divorce
so I I didn't understand these
explanations of this can happen or it
cannot happen or and I only did this
because my lawyers said to um
um
to just didn't make any sense to me and
and uh it looked like uh
she was kind of grabbing at straws
trying to figure out what
in fact to do
Mr Depp I like to just ask you about a
couple statements Miss heard makes in
this text message she first says just to
confirm that the cover letter is
completely private and has nothing to do
with any public record do you see that
the first sentence in the text message
yes I do do you know what cover letter
Ms heard is referring to no I don't okay
and then she says and only included the
domestic violence slash restraining
order stuff because I called the lawyer
when the cops were here and I didn't
know what to do or why that happened and
was scared do you see that yes do you
know what misheard is referring to when
she said that no
and then dropping down to the bottom
it says two lines up I thought you filed
do you see that yes and do you have any
understanding as to why misheard thought
you had already filed
no
no
I had I had on the the night of the 20th
was was when I
told her on the phone that I was going
to file
um
for divorce and in the way that I've
explained it
to keep everything nice and calm and
even
[Music]
um
but on the 23rd
Chief filed
and um so I I had I
hadn't had a chance to
file
um your honor I would move
um plaintiff's exhibit 487 specifically
the portions from page 492 to 494 into
evidence
so you just want page 492 to 494. yes
your honor it's a it's a 700 page
document so I just paid
I believe so this is 487 a certainly
that would make sense okay so 487 a
page 492 to 494 anyway
all right those two pages are in
evidence
two pages or three pages
four that would be three pages if that's
correct that's correct okay 492 to 494
okay
and could that please be published to
the jury
Mr Depp
Miss heard did end up seeking a
temporary restraining order against you
correct
yes she did and and what I believe you
or I said this but could you just remind
the jury what date was that
27th of May
and where were you when you learned that
Miss heard had
um actually filed a temporary
restraining order against you
I don't
I don't recall if we had left for Europe
as yet
um that is the Hollywood vampires for
the tour
so I was either in New York state
rehearsing and
preparing to go to Europe or I was
already in Europe I'd have to check the
the
tour dates
did you find out on the 27th or shortly
thereafter
no I found out on the 27th it was
everywhere
and what do you mean when you say it was
everywhere
it was um
it was multiplying
and multiplying and multiplying
throughout
media throughout
um
social media throughout
um
so-called sort of straight Media or
whatever
um
and
I was taken aback a bit
if we could take this down and please
pull up plaintiff's exhibit 411
Mr Depp is this some of the media
coverage that you were referring to
um
many things of this of this nature yes
many
and do you recall actually seeing the
specific article
I I don't remember seeing this specific
article
um
but there were
already plenty
and certainly
um
more than I was
happy to go through I I think once you
read one or two of them
um the general idea is is the
I mean the the point had been made
um
clearly
your honor I'd move um plaintiff's
exhibit 411 into evidence
um could we please take this down and
pull up uh plaintiff's exhibit 4 14.
thank you
Mr Depp yes do you recognize this
article at all
um I I remember
yeah I don't know if it was this one in
particular but I do remember seeing
all the various
reasons behind the or Reason per reasons
behind
um
her
needing to to get it
temporary restraining order
a tro against me which
they just started to uh
um
metastasized into
these uh
there were abuse allegations and there
was alcohol and there was drugs and
violence and
it just uh it was uh already
right then and there before
my eyes spinning out of control
and there was not a word that I could
say
your honor I would move plaintiff's
exhibit for 14 into evidence any
objection
and if we could take this down now
please and put up plaintiff's exhibit
409.
and your honor um if I could move
plaintiff's exhibit 409 into evidence as
well any objection with 409
no objection all right 409 in evidence
thank you
Mr Duff do you recall seeing this People
magazine article
yes I do
and when did you see it
right when it
was released right when it
came out
did you speak to anyone about this
article
thank you
yes I did who did you speak to
mostly friends and my
sister Christy
mostly friends
um and certainly
the the band
um
uh and my and my kids I had to
alert them that
there might be some ugly
ugly ugly things coming out
um that that were
most assuredly going to put me
in the position of um
uh some violent drug adult
alcoholic
uh
you know
um
just
reprobate
and I wanted
to warn them before
they were approached with the People
magazine covered in school
from by other kids you know
I I wanted to be able to tell explain
to them that this was going to be
visible and it's going to be everywhere
and
I apologize to them
that this was happening
had you ever been accused of physically
abusing a woman before this point no
no
how would you describe the impact of
these allegations at the time they were
made and Arnold if you could please take
this down
I I've I've
felt ill I felt sick
I mean I sick in a sense that
but I
there was no truth in it
there was no truth in whatsoever
and the fact that it was coming down on
me so hard
um and so quickly
and how it
it gained momentum around the world
um
and then you notice people
looking at you differently
and then you notice
calls
stop coming from
agents and producers
that sort of thing this was
this was a
this was a
this was before in fact the
metoo movement had
had
come around
this was a while before that so
I I couldn't have expected the metoo
movement to happen but
um once that happened then it it just
went into
Skyrocket mode
so you're
you're showered with uh
uh what was it you know you're running
between
drops of lava
you're trying to run between raindrops
that are
that that kill you
um and destroy you
so
I was very confused I was I was very
hurt
because
um
as I said before when you when you're in
a relationship and you
you do give
your
your truth to to
intimate truths to to that person that
you're with
and
then they start
to use all that
information like
and and stretch it out into something
that is
[Music]
completely shocking because it as I said
it it just didn't it just didn't happen
and
so I've felt like it was incredibly
cruel and church I felt it was treachery
it was it was uh
I don't know if she wanted me to
just
be erased or
drop dead or or just
let me stick around and allow her to
ruin my life
for a while and um and and and uh
and uh
go out of her way to
shame me
and hurt my kids and hurt people who
I've known for many many years
no it was uh
I mean to say that it was
unfair is is is about the largest
understatement that I
it's actually the smallest I'll just
type I mean the
it it it it it it
controlled my
every waking second from the moment that
I woke up
until the moment that I dropped
even on the road playing shows
you go out and you'd play for an hour
and a half or two hours
and you do your best to get through that
and there I can remember getting off of
the
finishing the show
getting on the bus with the other band
members
and just going to the back of the bus
and uh
this is just you know
you had to get it out so I just sat back
him
in the back of the bus and uh
cried and hid it from people
Mr Jeff did you ever have did you ever
discuss Miss heard's domestic abuse
allegations with any
um
producers or directors in the in the
movie industry
um
only if they fell into the category of
friends for example Tim Tim Burton
who was one of my dearest friends
who've known him since
we made Edward Scissorhands together in
1990 and we've been very very very close
friends ever since then
um
um yeah just
friends you know I
I
and and then of course
as we were on the road I you know the
fellas in the band you know Alice I'm
sorry uh
the
Alice Cooper is the singer of the
vampires who's a dear friend and
um
Jill Perry from Aerosmith is in the band
and he's also a dear friend and then the
um
a couple of the other members are just
yeah very close friends and uh
I was uh bereft of any
you just don't know what to say anymore
you just know what to
so I I tried not to talk about it very
much at all
but just a friend
Mr Deb
when did you and misheard divorce
when was the divorce final yes
the divorce was final
January
2017 on Friday the 13th
and how were how were your divorce
proceedings resolved ultimately
my my team of lawyers which included
two of my entertainment lawyers
a divorce attorney
um
and two and two more attorneys that were
on Blair Burke and someone else
they
they
I wanted to
I wanted to
for lack of a better word I wanted to
fight it
I want to divide it because it was
there because it wasn't an ounce not a
grain not a molecule of truth to it so I
want to define it
they
are
all right he was speaking about what he
wanted to do in the context of the
divorce I think the next one was gonna
be they said I don't know so okay
you can do your next question that's for
sure certainly
um
did you pay Miss hurt any money in
connection with your divorce
yes and how much was that
[Music]
um my first settlement she wanted uh
seven
million dollars
I believe that was the settlement wasn't
uh uh yes seven million dollars
and was there a joint statement that you
and Miss heard released
yes that's where I was getting
um
the advice that I was given was to not
to fight Jackson your honor hearsay
all right I'll sustain the objection
next question
um
who wrote The Joint statement
no idea
lawyers
did you approve the joint statement
before it was issued
I'll put it this way I I wasn't given
much of a choice
could we please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 408
and Mr Depp do you see um this second
paragraph from the bottom of this page
is that the joint statement that you and
misheard released together
that's the
joint statement that was released yes
and could you please read that joint
statement for the jury
our relationship was intensely
passionate
and at times volatile
but always Bound by love
neither party has made false accusations
for financial gain
there was never any intent of physical
or emotional harm
Amber Wishes the best for Johnny in the
future
Amber will be donating Financial
proceeds from the divorce to a charity
what happened after this joint statement
was issued Mr debb
IE what happened after that
um
I
I
I
suppose I suppose you know the next move
was to
start making
um
payments
to miss her
um they were scheduled
payments
um
and then a decision
um
misheard had
this heard it made statements to the
Press
saying that the 7 million was going to
be was 7 million was the settlement and
that 7 million was going to be split up
between two [ __ ] two Charities one was
the ACLU and the other was the
Children's Hospital of Los Angeles
which
it in in in fact was a a breach of the
agreement neither one of us were
supposed to
speak about
details money anything of that nature
so when Mr
preached that agreement
that was when I asked Ed White my
business manager
to
send the first
payments
directly to the charities
in Ms heard's name
and
after I did that
um
misheard
Miss Earth was very very angry that I
had made those first payments
and she went into a
kind of a tirade about how I should be
charged
double
the seven I should be charged 14 million
so that uh because she thought that I
was
looking for a tax break
Mr Depp between the time that the joint
statement was released and the time that
the op-ed came out how many movies did
you work on in that time period
if you can recall
when did the giant statement come out or
was it a
I'm sorry could we scroll up please
I'll withdraw the question for the
moment
in the time leading from the divorce
through the
um excuse me in the time period between
when your divorce was finalized and the
release of the op-ed in December 2018.
do you have an estimate as to how many
television or movie projects you worked
on
I
I don't exactly
I don't exactly
um
I believe there was another
maybe a smaller tour with with the
vampires
um
I like it's it's I don't remember it's
hard to remember
I've done too many movies that's okay
sorry uh your honor I apologize can we
please move into evidence exhibit 408
all right any objection before we
wait we don't have any objection to
um The Joint statement that was read but
they're okay so the article contains
here
all right we can redact that in and push
it and don't be a redacted 408 with just
a statement then is that what you're
talking about just that second to last
okay
all right that statement will be in
evidence once we get it redacted all
right thank you
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit one
Mr Depp do you recognize this document
Excuse me yes I do and what is it
this is MS heard's
op-ed for the Washington Post
that I believe came out in uh
December of
18.
I I recognize yes I certainly remember
this
and have you actually read this op-ed
yes uh and what do you think of it it's
contents
well it was a hell of a start I'd say in
terms of the
the title if you could if you could can
we scroll down a little bit uh just for
a second
um
because because I'd like to make a
a point
going
reading it and reading the
words that she had
written about
what was obviously
um
it was obviously referring to our
relationship it was obviously referring
to me two years ago
you know it all matched up and so it was
clearly about me
um
and then I read the rest of the article
where she talks about if you could go
down scroll down just a little bit
after the imagine a powerful man is a
ship
um
because she goes into
she she talks about in in in in this
section of the piece she talks about
the plight of of women
not just in Hollywood but in in general
in the world and there were
there were many things that I
did not disagree with in terms of this
this this part of the article
um
I I understand
um anyone's passion
to write the wrongs
that have that have been done for
countless years
against any
any being who's suffered
at the hands of domestic violence be it
women men
children
um
that's that's something of course
coming from my background
that I
I
am very very against
any bullying of any human being any
forced violence any
any
any Injustice
committed against
any human being
so all this part of the article was
strangely it was
it I understood it very well and I
I can applaud
some of this I can I can absolutely say
that I believe
that it was it was very well
um
done
with regard to violence against women or
violent violence against anyone
it just it just seemed kind of the
strange
other side
like a you know like a two-headed coin
Mr Depp um
did you experience any consequences
after the release of the op-ed
nearly absolutely and what were those
oh I will
I believe it was uh I
don't think it took
Disney very long maybe a couple of days
to uh
announce that uh
that uh that I had been
removed from the parts of the Caribbean
um films franchise
um
which I
learned about reading in a
in Reading one of these type of some
magazine for the article
where Sean Bailey was quoted
which was
very odd to me as
I have had many creative conversations
with the Disney people
um even to the point of where they were
asking me to come
back in right Pirates
sorry what Disney Executives told him
we can move on yeah if you want to just
restart
so I can read it out of
someone's article
but not from the man's mouth so what
happens next question uh Mr Deb what do
you what to what to your understanding
is the status of pirates six
at this point
yes
um I believe it's in dangle mode
Mr debb have you ever physically
assaulted misheard never
have you ever sexually assaulted
misheard
never certainly not
what have you lost as a result of
misheard making these allegations
against you
nothing less than everything
nothing less than everything
because
when the allegations were made
when the allegations were
rapidly circling the globe
um
telling people that I was uh
a drunken
cocaine fueled
Menace
who beat women
suddenly in my 50s
um
it's over you know you're done so
um what did it do to me
what effect did it have on me
ability this way no matter
the outcome of this trial
the second the allegations were made
against me
the accusations
the second that more and more
of these things as I said metastasized
and turned into
[Music]
fodder
for the media
um
once that happens
uh
or once that happened
I lost
then
there's to say
I lost
because
that is not a thing
that anyone is gonna
just
put on your back for a short period of
time
I will live with that
for the rest of my life
because of the allegations and because
it was such a high profile case so I
lost then
no matter the outcome of this trial
I'll carry that for the rest of my day
and uh
it never had to be that way it never had
to happen
and I don't
quite understand why it did
in the way that it did
I have no further questions your honor
all right
all right I think it's
you'd rather start tomorrow morning is
that occur
we're happy to start now your honor
well we go ahead and start a little bit
today just because
time is not on our side okay certainly
all right thank you
cross-examination
foreign
Mr Depp
good afternoon Mr Robin I'm I'm
happy that
in the last little bit we've we've
gotten to the reason
why we're here and I'd like to start
with that
um if you could please pull up
plaintiff's Exhibit 2
Michelle
[Music]
foreign
next page
in your honor I believe this is either
in evidence or has been stipulated as
part of the opening I assume no
objection to two no objection around
permission to publish yes
this article this opinion piece in the
middle of the page there Mr Depp this is
the opinion piece that Amber Heard wrote
In The Washington Post
that was published on December 18 2018.
correct
uh
let's say December 19th on it
at the top of the page doesn't that say
December 19 2018. go ahead I believe
that the 2018 was the online
was it not okay so December 18th
December 19th this piece in the middle
of the page is the opinion piece
misheard wrote right
um
it
could you make it a little bigger
getting smaller
and this is what you're suing her over
correct
um
I'm suing her
over
um definition
um and
the various
falsities that she used
to
[Music]
bring my life to an end
and you understand many things
you understand Mr Depp that you cannot
you you are not suing her for any damage
allege damage or any accusations
she made prior to writing this article
you're you're aware of that you'd agree
with that right
did you say that again
Mr rottenborn you are not
bringing a lawsuit against her bringing
her into court in Virginia for anything
that she did prior to writing this
article correct you know that you can't
do that right I I have to say that I I
as I said
at the top of this I've never seen this
version
of
the op-ed piece uh the version that I
saw was the other one that I identified
that was on the 18th this is on the 19th
I believe the 18th
in two years before possibly sorry
was quite possibly
um
maybe that was the online version that
came out first
two years before the online and the
print version came out
in 2016 Amber obtained a domestic
violence restraining order against you
from a California Court correct
yes sir and in obtaining that domestic
violence restraining order in May
2016. she accused you of domestic abuse
right
yes sir and
Michelle if you could blow up the
um the third paragraph down please
and in the opinion piece that's before
you published in the Washington Post she
wrote then two years ago I became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse correct
I I can't say correct she wrote it and
the person doesn't contain your name
correct
no it does not no and other than
mentioning the fact of abuse accusations
that were made two years prior to the
publication of this article
the opinion piece doesn't contain any
details of your time together correct
oh I've I think that her
um I I think it's very easy to write a
piece
and put the finger on someone without
saying their name uh
there are sneaky ways of
um writing things and as I've
seen also
um with the ACLU
and their team had to say
uh they clearly
describe to misheard that I'll move to
strike this is hearsay your honor all
right
and and I appreciate so it's evidence
sorry next question okay
thank you your honor Mr Depp I I
appreciate you've gotten a a lot of
chance to talk and and I'm trying to be
respectful the Court's time and the
jury's time so I'm going to ask you that
that question again because I think it's
a it's a pretty simple yes or no
question which is you'd love it
nothing simple in this case other than
mentioning the fact
of abuse accusations made two years
prior this opinion piece does not
contain any details of your time
together yes or no
it contains a
fragments
this piece here I don't know is this
word for word with the other piece and
the article discusses proposed
legislation that which he just talked
about correct you'd agree with that
right
yes yeah and it discussers discusses
Amber's experiences after she had
separated from you you'd agree with that
right
two years ago I became the public face
for domestic violence
2018
2016
it seemed to me that it the puzzle was
going to work no matter your angles or
okay okay so so
I'll take that response as a no that
this piece does not discuss
uh that this piece does not discuss
anything prior to misheard separating
from you and it only discusses her
experiences her biographical experiences
after she separated from you
correct I I can't say that okay now
you're claiming that due to Amber's
allegations of abuse you can't be in
Pirate six
correct
um I'm saying that after
everything had uh
um
basically hit its media targets
and the hit pieces kept coming
it would be
I mean I would be a real simpleton to
not think that there was an effect on my
career based on Ms hurts
words
whether they mention my name or not
you became aware prior to the
publication of this op-ed that you were
likely out for pirate six the Disney was
considering dropping or or dramatically
shrinking a role correct
no
can you pull up
defense exhibit 113 please
um let's go to let's
um
let's go to 114 please
are you changing on me yeah I'm sorry
your honor but it's the next one so it's
okay 114.
all right
sorry one more let's 115 please
22 October 2018. It's Gonna Roll
sorry
do you have the questions I I did I was
just giving him time to to read
do you see the the date of this article
um beneath those bullet points is
October 25th 2018. do you see that yes I
do and
do you see that the headline hide the
rum Johnny Depp is about as Jack Sparrow
and Disney's Pirates of the Caribbean
yes objection hearsay
here's the objection it's I was asking
if he became aware I'm not offering an
article for the truth his awareness
right now I'm asking if his awareness
that he was likely out that question
thank you okay so Mr Depp yes were you
aware that as of October 25th 2018 about
two months before this op-ed was
published that it was being reported as
it is in this article that Johnny Depp
is out as Jack Sparrow in Disney's
Pirates of the Caribbean film franchise
as actor battles Financial issues and
personal dramas were you aware of that
um I wasn't aware of that but it doesn't
surprise me given that two years had
gone by of
just constant
um
worldwide talk about me being this wife
Peter
understood but you I'm sure that Disney
was trying to
um
cut ties
to be safe the metoo movement was in
full swing at that point right and to
the extent they were trying to cut ties
to be safe that was
as long as two months before you wrote
the op-ed
[Music]
I'm sorry the question to the extent
that Disney was trying to cut ties with
you as you say to be safe that was as
much as two months prior to you
published or to to misheard publishing
the op-ed in the Washington Post correct
objective foundation
out loud if you can answer it
October is two months before December
that's correct
um
but it's odd that they were going to
release me from my role as Captain Jack
Sparrow yet kept me on every ride across
the world in the Pirates of the
Caribbean rides I'm in the Los Angeles
or the Hollywood one or whatever it is
three or four times
um Shanghai I mean all over the world so
they didn't remove my character from the
rides they didn't stop selling
merchandise of Captain Jack Sparrow they
didn't stop selling dolls of Captain
Jack Sparrow they didn't stop selling
anything
they just
didn't
want there to be something
trailing behind me that they'd find
and you aren't aware you said pirate six
in your view is dangling you're not
aware of if or when pirate six will be
made correct
and the fact is Mr Depp if Disney came
to you with 300 million dollars and a
million alpacas
nothing on this Earth would get you to
go back and work with Disney on a
Pirates of the Caribbean film because
that is true Mr Rutland born
and you couldn't identify a single movie
that you did between the divorce and the
op-ed in response to miss Myers
questions just now you said there was a
small tour
um of your band between that but you can
identify a single movie that you did
in the year or two prior to the op-ed
correct
uh
I I have to tell you that when I'm
working on a film I do my work and when
I'm wrapped on that film I've done my
work and I move on to the next so I I I
haven't seen
the majority of my films I've seen a few
only if I had to
but so I I it doesn't come right away to
my head that's films are not the first
thing that I think about
and you spent a long time talking about
the impact of the abuse allegations
um made in misheards obtaining the
temporary restraining order in or the
domestic violence restraining order in
May 2016 right
true and you said you testified that you
wanted to fight it right
but the fact is you never fought the
allegations in court in 2016. it was
only after misheard published this op-ed
in 2018
that you that you fought them you never
tried to fight him in 2016 did you I was
advised by my attorneys not to fight
in fact you signed the not only that we
read a statement but let's let's pull up
um
okay
cool though
let's pull up
dx1458 please
and Mr Depp you see that this uh this
says marriage of Depp uh correct I see
that it's a legal document can you
scroll to the signature page Michelle
please
this was a document that you signed as
part of your divorce proceedings correct
that's my signature indeed yes okay
um your honor move for admission of this
document any objection to that document
no objection all right 1458 in evidence
may we publish please yes sir
Mr debb that is your signature on the
right correct
yes it is
dated August 15 2016 right
but it says yes and
um this is you you you were
this is a document you signed right
for the third time that is my signature
yes let's go to paragraph 27 please
[Music]
paragraph paragraph 27 okay
and this paragraph is a joint statement
that both sides agreed to release
and if you look in the the block quote
there it's contains the quote
or that contains the statement neither
party has made false accusations for
financial gain neither party has made
false accusations for financial gain did
I read that right
you did Mr Robinson Michelle
and that was a document you signed in
August of 2016.
correct is that the same one that I
signed three times before yes that's the
four I just I want to make clear that
you signed that in the summer of 2016.
two years before misheard published her
op-ed
I don't have anything else for the for
the day your honor okay okay all right
we'll go ahead and take our evening if
that's okay
that works for me I was gonna stop you
at the Vlog anyway so that's fine all
right ladies and gentlemen that's the
that'll include our day-to-day again
don't do any outside research do not
talk to anybody we'll see in the morning
okay all right have a good evening
nothing
all right again sir just don't discuss
your testimony with anybody since you're
still testifying and to include your
attorneys okay we'll see in the morning
okay 10 o'clock good yeah thank you
thank you
all right
calculator
and then
um I grapple review for just quick
sector five
um
yourself
foreign
foreign